hello everyone this is mr. Anderson  whip-it no wasn't a it's not a matrix  thing never mind  today I start and confinement and  everybody knows what this means this  means I am a proper voice actor died  nobody can say any different Oh  anyway if by some weird turn of events  you see this video before confinement go  to Lord bongs channel there's gonna be a  link right now go over and watch it it's  amazing  go back to episode 1 watch it all the  way up to episode 3 the time will fly  because the animation is just that good  I've seen a lot of people saying that it  should be on Adult Swim I wholeheartedly  agree it should be I'm gonna tell my  kids about this Sunday  [Music]  I Love You Lord Bom